-I want to talk World Cup
for a minute.
-Ugh.
-I know, I know.
But I know you're German,
and Germany, wow, wow, wow.
-I mean, how can you, like, win,
like, win the whole thing,
and then, next time around,
I think we're, like,
the last one on the list
this time around.
-Yeah.
-How is that possible?
-Yeah, I'm sorry to -- Yeah.
It must've been a bummer.
-I mean,
I feel bad for all of them.
-Yeah, me, too.
-But you know what?
At the end of the day,
may the best one win, right?
-May the best one win.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So maybe it's just time
for someone else to win.
-I guess so. Still...
-Someone else
is better this year.
-At least you guys
made it to the World Cup.
The U.S. didn't even --
they didn't even qualify at all.
I had nobody
to root for or nothing.
But I thought this would be a
fun thing we could do tonight --
we could play a game.
-Yeah.
-I think we should have
our very own Germany versus USA
World Cup
with a foosball table.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-You down with that?
-Yes.
-All right, let's go.
Come on.
♪♪♪♪
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
That -- This --
-I know.
I don't know if
I'm very good at that, either,
to be honest with you.
-All right.
-Right along
with our German soccer players.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway...
-Now, look,
I don't want to just play
a regular old game of foosball.
Let's make things interesting,
okay?
We're gonna do this blindfolded.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Whoa!
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Ooh.
-Jesus!
-Sorry.
I thought
you were gonna put yours on.
I have no idea what's happening.
[ Laughter ]
This feels --
Wow, all right.
Okay, all right.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just gonna do this.
-50 Shades of Foosball.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
50 Shades of Foosball.
Oh, my God.
♪♪♪♪
All right.
There we go.
All right, now...
[ Cheering ]
-I'm ready.
-Questlove,
give me some foosball --
-So who put this thing on you?
Are you actually wearing one?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
-The blindfold.
-I put it on me.
I can't have you put it on me.
You can't see anything.
-Is he cheating?
[ Audience "Nos" ]
Okay, good.
-One of these --
Oh, here.
All right, now, I'm gonna put
the ball in the slot here, okay?
-Yes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Go.
-Now -- Hey, watch it.
[ Laughter ]
Don't -- Don't push
your thing that far.
[ Laughter ]
-I haven't even --
Why, is the ball in?
[ Laughter ]
-No, but there's --
-Is it in?
-No, but there's balls --
♪♪♪♪
There's balls in play,
there's balls in play.
Now, look, I'm going to --
-Is it happening?
-So, here you go --
on the count of three,
I'm gonna drop the ball in,
and then we go --
Wait. I got to just --
I want to peek for a second,
sorry.
I'm trying to score on...
-Geez.
-I know, sorry.
I'm going to score on this --
So this --
I have to score this way.
-Halftime!
[ Laughter ]
I have to score this way,
and you have to score this way.
-I score to the right.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, sure.
-I'm ready.
-Me too.
I know, but all right,
here we go.
All right.
Gosh!
Calm down, man!
Here we go.
Are you ready for this?
-Yes!
-All right!
Questlove, can you give me
some foosball-playing --
Watch it right there!
[ Laughter ]
I swear to goodness it's gonna
really be a long summer for me.
[ Laughter ]
All right,
watch it, watch it, watch it.
Ow.
All right, ready?
-Watch it?
I can't watch it.
-One, two, three.
♪♪♪♪
All right, good, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How do you know
where the ball is?!
How do you
know where the ball is?
-I don't know where the ball is!
-We need more balls!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
♪♪♪♪
-Stop!
-Stop one second!
-I'm exhausted!
-No, stop one second, stop.
-I am exhausted.
-Put more balls in.
We need more balls.
-We need more balls!
-You want another ball in there?
-I want another ball.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We need -- like,
how many balls you got?
[ Laughter ]
Put more balls in.
-Okay.
-Otherwise,
this is never gonna work.
-Ow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
What?
-I don't know!
I don't know.
[ Audience chants "U.S.A.!" ]
-What happened?
-USA! USA!
[ Laughing ]
♪♪♪♪
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
You guys, we'll be right back!
We'll be right back!